it's easy to spend a couple thousand a  year to see that's another story Susie  for example for me to you to spend  anywhere you know enormous hear it let's  hear what you spend when you go shop I  can't say it because my thumb you can  can hear it under that tell we're gonna  make them get that I'm spending too much  I can say tell me you ended up  I can I can I guess ok guess when you go  shopping on a regular day alright so  what do you shop it here big what do you  shop it and I can tell you what do you  like to shop at and I can tell you I  like you know you like going to Europe  ok so we go to Europe you're not good so  you spend you know between thousand I  could spend 20,000 so that's easy I know  then I have a big smile yeah so maybe me  you need to go to Europe and Russia  definitely you got to spend 40 they'll  give us the discount will be there yes  they should